and let us be mindful of the experience
of those from Swaziland and those from
nauru and Gibraltar just kill us now
this self-care is important is it not
now let's have some fun education is
self-care too is it not
[Music]
uh
Bob father
in you and broken man I see worthy
opponents
do you accept this moment
no no uh no we we gotta go yeah actually
yeah we gotta we got some friends and
this woman and this
it's kind of a long story but we yeah we
gotta go you see we can't let you leave
just yet what trust me
you will be a better man when this is
all over
Bob you okay
you truck guys
it's just some wholly organic
barbiturates from the bark of a tree
found in the Brazilian Rainforest think
of it as Nature's truth serum
you see I've made it my mission in life
to educate those the world has left
behind
you like games Bob father
welcome to the ultimate game what game
the one you are already playing
I know